no per tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j e
benvenuti anche ad un nuovo blog ragazzi
oggi ci avevo proprio voglia di fare
blogger a che non vedevo l'ora di
iniziare
per il semplice fatto che va
innanzitutto dobbiamo dire la parte
della settimana come in ogni blog dilaga
l'iphone art della settimana è questa
che è una parata su scribblenauts fatta
da mary che si aggiudica la parte della
settimana bravissima comunque ragazzi
vorrei trattare un punto in particolare
allora la scorsa settimana mi avete
linciato mi volevano uccidere mi
volevate tipo prendere a cazzotti perché
mi avete detto fuori j
purché non hai fatto il [ __ ] punto
posta quindi ragazzi in questa settimana
mi sono dato da fare la tua settimana
per andare a far aprire punto posta che
ovviamente non l'ho ancora fatto ragazzi
non lo sfiora fatto perché non ho
trovato un secondo di tempo raga non vi
giuro non ho trovato un secondo di tempo
è più avanti gli spiegherò perché sono
giustificato questa volta comunque ve lo
dico sicuramente nel prossimo blog
sicuro al cento per cento ci servirà al
punto posto assicuro fatto che in questo
blog non posso scartare i fatti che mi
mandate ancora devo vedere bene come
strutturare i blog finali che saranno
composti di pet dalla phone arte da
settimana dallo scattare un pacco che mi
mandate da rispondere alle vostre
domande vorrei a julio c'è anche
qualcos'altro per renderli più
interattivi comunque belli da vedere
perché sempre fare magari non so domande
domande domande domande dopo un po rompe
le palle quindi voglio fare molte più
cose messe insieme in modo che ogni blog
sia unico nel suo genere quindi ragazzi
aspettate ancora prossimo blog quindi
ragazzi ray che da adesso possiamo
partire con le domande me ne sono
arrivate veramente tantissime e direi di
partire con la prima noi adoriamo fa vj
e io adoro noi ci sarà il prossimo lucca
comics
sì avevo pensato di venire al 99,9 per
cento verrò a lucca comics and games che
mi pare sia all'inizio di novembre si
comunque verrò a lucca comics and games
e novi 30 100 ma bull d'avola no
filippo collavino mi faresti un
autografo please subito kg 98 plus
domanda per i blog che anime seguì in
questo momento sto seguendo l'attacco
dei giganti siamo alla quattordicesima
puntata domani esce la quindicesima sto
seguendo ne seguo una no perché io ho
amici che seguono cinque anime insieme
non so come mi chiama io non esco
seguirne uno non ha più che altro perché
io non ho tempo se non ne guarderei
anche un po di più comunque e non sono
uno che sta tutto il giorno a guardare
anime ne guardo guardo una puntata alla
settimana proprio giusto quando esce ma
vi risponde dai un nome al tuo fan dom
questo è cosa ci avevo pensato ci avevo
pensato più volte però non mi piace
tantissimo questa cosa di dare un nome
al pan dom
in generale comunque avevo pensato
perché non uscite con delle cose
improponibili la più azzeccata mi era
stata suggerita da un mio amico gli
aveva consigliato fan vj propostito fan
di j tutto attaccato
però non è una cosa che uso perché può
non mi piace come suona va bene
no christian calafiore fa vi risponde
che musica ascolti qual è il tuo artista
o gruppo preferito allora non ho un
gruppo non ho un artista poco in
particolare preferito scotto diciamo un
po di tutto però se devo fare una scelta
precisa diciamo che ascolto coli che
ascolto di più sono i linkin park e news
invece come artista pop singolo michael
jackson mi piace abbastanza quindi
questi sono i tre che proprio
singolarmente ascolto di più se no poi
ascolta ingenerare un po tutto domanda
per infatti o hai anche tu le orecchie
si sono sono queste le orecchie non so
perché me l'ha fatto in tanti questa
domanda ma sono reti contro il mio
orecchio destro di strano c'è sono solo
perché ho le orecchie un po più gonfie
del normale ma siete razzisti con le
orecchie gonfie maledetti comunque va
beh se cielo non le vedi cielo wolf lupo
dietro di te c'è una foto sei tu da
piccolo
penso che intenda allora aspetta un
attimo che cosa faccio una panoramica
penso dipenda ovvio che siamo
digitalizzati sto muovendo la webcam con
il mouse mistico lab è comunque ben si
intenda questa qui il suono di seacrest
e la foto di quando sono piccolo
ciò anche pannolone quindi lì mi serviva
di più perché mi caga bob posto proprio
adesso mi cadde addosso negli horror è
il pannolone non lo metto però ci avevo
quando l'ho neanche al tempo e va beh sì
che sono io da piccolo non sense bnp
fuck you favi per caso ai peli sotto
l'ascella e no però o le ascelle sotto i
piedi gol di gsa il qualche animale no
sono l'unico animale in casa purtroppo
toia toia 2000 falliti scrivi su
instagram
questa cosa è non abbastanza strana
allora raga questa ve la devo dire
soltanto che è successa una cosa un po
strano allora diciamo che non sto
parlando sotto perché sto dando su
instagram
praticamente è successo che sono entrato
su instagram scritto crea nuovo utente e
shell in un utente fa vj famiglia è già
stato usato ovviamente non capitava il
nika che mi poteva nickname ovviamente è
andata così e ho detto ma edizione non
posso creare instagram perché è una foto
nickname
poi mi è venuto un lampo di genio ma non
è che sto deficiente quando ha creato fa
vj su instagram ha messo una password
del tipo stupida come fa vj allora ho
provato a scrivere il nome utente fa vj
password fa vj ho provato ad entrare e
il mio entrato magicamente quindi
ragazzi o instagram
adesso su instagram sono fatti j non la
mente si tuffa vj mi riconoscete perché
mi faccio una foto mi caccia foto a
destra ok ragazzi
pensate su instagram e vedete sta roba
sono io la vedesse tra le foto quindi
ragazzi se riconoscete o individuo
vuol dire che è instagram e qualunque
schiette favi già normalmente non è
difficile come alla dunque era favia
instagram
e adesso sì comunque ci tengo a
precisare che questo non è rubare un
account
a una persona perché comunque quello era
un mio account ma ha creato muri e io
glielo ripetuto è comunque in teoria
sarebbe appropriazione di identità la
parte solo perché lui comunque si
spacciava per me detto questo ragazzi
tengo a dirvi anche una cosa una cosa
molto importante se per caso vedete
qualcuno che si spaccia per me se per
caso vedete qualcuno che scrive a nome
mio
che non sia o del canale questo dove
metto video fa vige tv normalmente o
della pagina di facebook che mette in
ogni video nella descrizione o di
instagram che mi sono fatto adesso se
per caso non c'è qualcuno che si spaccia
per me è non è in queste tre in questi
tre social ragan non sono io che se lo
dico perché molti ci cascano molti ci
credono purtroppo è
cc facile anche cascarci
purtroppo è così quindi ragazzi se
capita sappiate non sono soft ti è mai
caduto il telecomando ps ti stimo
continua così grazie comunque è sì mi è
caduto il telecomando diverse volte una
decina tutte perché prima mente quando
melo lancio faccio così quindi capita a
volte che faccio tipo la roma leggere il
casco aterra faccio la figura del
deficiente poi pensato taglio comuni
così una volta lo devo tenere per sé
quello che dovevi calais perché sono
esilaranti quando faccio una faccia del
tipo e poi cade come un deficiente io a
guardarlo così perché non c'è voglia di
alzarmi comunque ragazzi se mi cade è
capitato e capiterà ancora di sicuro e
con questo mi collego anche la prossima
domanda che mi chiede axel di olocco fa
vigeva il telecomando a fine video dove
lo prendi sembra che qualcuno te lo
lanci ragazzi questa è questo mistero
come un mistero il mistero del secondo
bracciano perché nessuno sa che io oltre
a questo braccio qui ho anche questo
e quell'altro braccio posso fare questa
attenzione magia madonna che mangi
acquisito un trucchi professioni ragazzi
i professionisti non sanno fare se
guardate mi lancio il telecomando con
l'altra mano o mio dio
c'era e questa è una cosa proprio oggi
vuole della tecnica perché certi ci
vuole poco allenamento per far costruire
addirittura faccio di scambio leva dai
ragazzi e io mi almeno lancio con
l'altra mano cioè mio dio non è una cosa
così non mi sembra neanche tanto
difficile va beh sì in effetti sembra
perché il braccio non si vede però me lo
prendo con l'altro c'è il lancio con
queste lo prendo questo cioè una cosa
normale spero che siate contenti
ferdinando rotolo fermatelo fare la
domanda che secondo me tutto il popolo
italiano ti chiede è la seguente ma tu
hai le orecchie ancora mio zio marche
razzismo nei confronti delle mie
orecchie ragazzi c'è una cosa
impressionante ma fa mi ti piace del
noto no kevin schettino comunque ragazzi
ho finito le domande anche per oggi
perché sennò andiamo avanti lagane
abbiamo un miliardo anche di alcune
griffate continuamente ma non ancora
risposto rispondero nel prossimo ci
tenevo a prendermi questa piccola parte
a fine blog per dirvi una cosa che è in
molti di voi già sanno quelli che hanno
messo mi piace a pagina facebook lo
sanno perché l'ho già scritto lì a
partire raga a partire da mercoledì se
tutto va bene
non metterò più vivo fino al 7 di agosto
il 7 di agosto perché perché vado in
vacanza magari fatti tutti su facebook
mi avete scritto pali stai tranquillo
predichi questa vacanza perché comunque
rimette tutti voi sanno che ci mette
spero tutti sappiate che ci metto così
tanto a fare video infatti tutti mi
hanno detto favi assolutamente brandy
questa vacanza perché te la meriti
siete stati tutti molto molto gentili a
dirmi queste cose quindi grazie ragazzi
il tasto dolente di tutta questa
faccenda è che il 12 agosto
io ritorno 7 il 12 agosto riparto altri
la settimana non ci sono quindi i
ragazzi devo devo veramente vedere poi
quando torna dovrà farvi di nuovo un
mazzo tanto per riuscire a coprire
almeno una settimana fra che ovviamente
voglio cercare di farmi stare senza
video il meno possibile comunque ragazzi
questa cosa ve l'ho detta la maggior
parte di voi che non sapeva già da una
pagina di facebook
per chi non lo sapeva e l'ho detto
comunque sappiate capire alla fine
agosto sui parquet tranquillamente
soltanto agosto dato che un periodo di
vacanza anche un po per tutti sarà un po
fatto a tappe ma fine agosto state
tranquilli che si riparte
tranquillamente come sempre comunque
server caso sentite tanto la mia
mancanza come quando ci sono i periodi
di pausa lo scrivo su facebook
guardatevi magari le playlist 13 vecchie
video che vi siete persi
guardatevi qualche cosa che vi arretrato
che ho fatto alla range de persi
e niente comunque sappiate che io non
muoio vado soltanto in vacanza come un
essere umano normale e ritorno poi
tranquillamente quindi state tranquilli
detto questo direi che posso chiudere il
blog ragazzi se vi dove è piaciuto come
al solito ho scelto commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come non i
video trovate una descrizione della
century city iscrivetevi che ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vitobello
ragazzi
[Musica]